President Biden's problems at the border
are about to get a lot worse so right
now the largest migrant Caravan in over
a year is marching right towards the
United States it is said to be up to
7,000 people strong one of the
organizers of the Caravan is speaking
out and he says President Biden should
have seen it coming Jo bid
Administration has uh has lost the ball
had lost the power in in America
has has not been paying attention what's
happening every country has been just
providing their rights
charging them 20 30 or $40 and then just
pushing them in pushing them in all the
way to the Mexican borders where's the
American intelligence don't they know
that the all the countries are
conspiring against the United States to
make sure they have this crisis I'm
confused he's the organizer okay all
right so this happening as Homeland
Security secretary mayorcas refuses to
say how many illegal immigrants have
been released into the country how many
people has this administration led into
the country let me say at the outset
that uh our job would be a lot easier if
the broken immigration system wasix Mr
secretary I want a number how many
people have you led into this country I
I should also okay I I'll give you the
number it's about 6 million about 1.7
million as know goway where are all
these people residing where where did
the six million people go Senator you
speak of encounters and let me um no
would you answer my questions where did
these six million people go are you
keeping track of them when an individual
is indeed released they are released
into immigration enforcement
proceedings caliana border crisis and
disaster this magnitude would be the
biggest problem for any Administration
but for the Biden Administration it's
like the fourth biggest crisis that is
that are on their plates right now and
this is true chaos chaos and crisis not
just in a tweet um we're in the Press
briefing room this is real and you have
a Homeland Security secretary he
probably been under oath a dozen times
or more testifying to Congress who can
never answer these questions because he
can't he's not willing to answer them
truthfully so he doesn't answer them at
all he doesn't know how many people he
doesn't know who they are how many they
are where they are why they're here if
they'll ever stop coming and I you know
it is the number one disapproval rating
for Joe Biden on any major issue is
border security and immigration and I
think it's been super smart for this
issue to not just be seen about
immigration but also border security
because there lots of people don't want
to talk about immigration they say it's
about people you get so many more young
people voters of color Suburban women on
your side when you talk about border
security because there they see they're
trying to stop the fenel number one kill
of 18 to 45y olds in our nation this is
about National sovereignty people in
this country know Dana we have spent
billions of dollars over
decades defending the borders of other
countries and they think it's high time
we do it here the Sienna poll Sienna
College poll that came out here in New
York I thought was just eye popping week
before last or last week what did it say
Well it said we have triartisan
agreement in New York of all places a
majority of Democrats a majority of
Republicans a majority of Independents
all say that quote the migrants in New
York is a serious problem eight and 10
overall downstate Upstate male female
Catholics majority of Jewish people in
New York everybody agrees this is a
problem and they say they agree with
Eric Adam
that is going to quote destroy New York
City now that's in New York where Joe
Biden's under 50% against Donald Trump a
state he won massively this is the issue
that also France is dealing with now
Germany the Swiss just elected someone
who's running on this so it's everywhere
and and I think if you're losing people
in New York who are living with it every
single day it tells you something about
the rest of nation well Harold to that
point that 9 million so the cost of
Biden's border crosses not just 9 mil so
New York spending $2 billion dollar
Chicago has put $150 million aside
Denver $24 million aside and then Joe
barelli who's on the city council here
in New York he said we are spending more
per migrant per year to live in New York
City than we pay New York city employees
who have to live in New York City it
feels untenable but are they doing
anything about it not enough um I think
Senator Johnson whom I don't agree with
all of the time he was right to ask that
question of the secretary uh this is a
national security challenge has been
from the outset and only proliferates as
one in light of some of the things that
kellyanne has laid out and we' have
eloquently talked about on this show for
a long time as we talk about polling you
know I when you look there are three or
four things that confound me in politics
and polling today one is if you poll
most Americans and parents and I am one
you say do you want to regulate big tech
companies to help them not offer these
dangerous algorithms to kids and make
young girls and young boys do things
they should 90% 9 to one you ask people
should we have some uh should we fight
crime and end this cashless bail 8 to
one people say we should absolutely do
it because it's going to help us hold
more people accountable if you ask us
what we should do with guns 8 to one
people want to make sure some people
can't have guns who are mentally unfit
to have them in this issue here to your
point kellyan there is no doubt it cuts
across we sometimes talk about race too
much I'm an American I happen to be
black I want my border secure I want
crime fought aggressively I want people
held accountable I want people to be
treated Bary at the border but at the
same time you shouldn't be able to come
to the border and say things are bad at
home let me in these are things that
should just be done and I hope that
Republicans and Democrats alike and I
would agree my party has more
responsibility at this moment because
the president of the United States is a
Democrat I would hope we not only can
answer the question of how many people
we've let in let's begin to act and act
quickly forcefully and act smartly which
we're not doing right now this morning
Greg on Newsroom Fran Townsen who used
to be Homeland Security advisor at the
White House she reminded everybody that
Hezbollah has a pretty big foothold in
South America especially Venezuela and
we have 600,000 known Goda aways this
year alone fiscal year 23 and 169 have
been caught on the terror watch list so
the chances of a Hezbollah agent in the
United States operating is probably
pretty high yes but if you say that then
you you run into the Skittles argument
remember that there could be one bad
Skittle yes uh we're learning you can't
have everything which is you can't have
open board in a bottomless safety net
because ultimately we become a third
world country and it's not because of
people coming here from the third world
it's because all the money that is
needed to take care of all of us will be
spread so thin that it won't exist
anymore we will not have the basic
Services because we won't be able to
handle everybody this is where the
American dream implodes used to be that
you came here you worked hard you raised
a family and you Ma your fortune
whatever that is could be opening up a
drugstore uh whatever now it's come here
and we give you the fortune whether it's
free Hotel free food free health care at
the expense of people who've worked here
for decades it worked hard for decades
so not only we stealing from past
Achievers we're also preventing new
Achievers from learning about this type
of America you know the idea of work and
reward America is no longer the land of
opportunity it's the land of free stuff
paid for by the people who can now not
afford eggs and gas that can't last mean
while the hard left is creating a
population that it loves a dependent
population population dependent on the
government te so they won't dare
question that government when it
increases the boil of its slow socialism
te te the government te government te
you like that I did yeah you can't say
tit you just did no I don't know I'm not
sure you just did can you well you just
did the producers have already checked
out yeah let's check out what you have
to say about immigration and a caravan
another you don't happen to be black
your parents were black they made love
and you had a beautiful baby be proud of
yourself Harold believe me I'm very
proud of it good I'm not allowed to be
proud you could be proud uh so can make
you black 1% so do you remember before
the runup to the Ukraine war where us
intelligence said hey Russia we see you
guys amassing hundreds of thousands of
men on the border of Ukraine we have
communications intercepts we have
satellite imagery we see what you're
doing you're saying we don't see the
whole Western Hemisphere coming up in
Caravans through Central America into
Mexico right into Texas Dana of course
we see it we see exactly what they're
doing and we don't do anything about it
we had a former CIA Guy come on Prime
Time the other day and he said the CIA
makes money on the side with with drug
trafficking it's like a side hustle
because their funding isn't big enough
so they do some you know Black Ops in
order to boost their budget and hide it
from congressional oversight and then
use it for dirty stuff so that's what
they're doing with the drug trafficking
and one of the reasons one of many
reasons Donald Trump Was Defeated was
because the CIA had had it with this guy
because he was threatening the cash flow
that and the China tariffs among many
other things so when you threaten the
donor money and you threaten the
Democrat voters and you def threaten the
CIA cash flow it's a problem Joe Biden
is such an agreeable empty suit he's
just letting it all happen wait you're
saying the CIA is funding Itself by the
drug trade yeah they take a cut that's
what the former CIA guy told me those
black guys may not want you
after all right coming up if you dare
challenge President Biden his allies
will accuse you of racism hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else